hey youtubers is Charlie thank you
everyone that so many questions on the
Star Wars trailer
is gonna be my Q&A for that as well as
Mike huge thank you for 500 K
here's the I cannot thank you guys
enough for how awesome you been you have
no idea what a dream come true it is
that I actually get to make youtube
videos
for a living thank you everyone for just
spending your free time talking about
movie in TVs with me its utter complete
nonsense
I just cannot think of a better way to
spend the rest my life so here's the
next 500 K
thank you so much to all the people who
found me when I had one subscriber
or the villages family yesterday now
let's talk about some star words so
big news we actually get some questions
answered official questions answered
since the trailers come out
most notably like you some other people
on trailer word at work immediately
recognizable
specifically the really evil sounding
boys it actually ended up being in the
circus
which is a bit of a surprise because the
way sounds nothing like them I talk a
little bit about him as we get into
rumors and spoilers the into the video I
want to see lights by the warning now
I will speak about a few the rumors this
is again in a couple the questions
but I will do like a section at the end
brawl talk about some of the bigger
rumors all states but the warning again
whenever I get to that
you got a question for one Sheena big
ingest do you think they'll have a
general counsel be built by Luke in this
time line
now like we saw on the prequels but this
is actually where the first big rumor
comes in
there is a British actor that has Star
Wars Episode 7 listen on his CB
and he's written down the role a Padawan
so if there's a Padawan
in the movie and it's not like a dark
path 1 like not a sad situation
there has to be some sort of Academy
situation happening whether or not
there's a lot of them
remains to be seen his name is Sam car
they're actually number back tears that
were revealed as Star Wars 7 cast
members based on this
CB listing is from this place called
spotlight UK
I don't know there's any truth to it but
if there's a bunch of actors
listing Star Wars Episode seven on their
CV if no one's professionally
slapping them in the face for lying
about episode 7 enemy that's probably
true
question number two deal or for ever as
art
all storm troopers clones that is a good
question I saw a lot of confusion about
this
no not all of them are clones so part of
the reason
that rebels exist like the store was
rebels cartoon is to set the stage for
the Galaxy
and some other ideas that we're going to
see and
new trilogy even though the series takes
place you know
we way in the past if you saw that
episode there was an upset with Ezra
bridger joining the Imperial Academy
the crater on the Tamil rebels the
Empire starts taking recruits again
so that by the time the original trilogy
you know it says four five and six
most those storm troopers are actually
regular people
they just recruited for the most part I
think the clones are said to have died
out during the wars
I'm sure there's still some floating
around but when you see like legions the
storm troopers
most in a more recruits that are trained
questionable 3
deacon as it's a trap planet you say
you think there on Mon column re:
that's when the better rumors i've seen
like they were filming on Island
in a lake so far the places that they
could possibly
be visiting like all the planets in
Episode 7 here's some the places that
they filmed
so the place that I was talking about
you know it's a trap yes
Mon column re: they filmed Ireland
Skellig Michael
that's the place that everybody thinks
could be Mon Calipari
just because they've films really tiny
island could've been the entrance to
this undersea living area
can also been the place in the trailer
with others X means flying over that big
lake
as in tumors that one of the original
cast members could be living there but
their little
far-fetched so I'm not connected to deep
into it but on the other filming
locations where Tunisia and Abu Dhabi
in addition to playing with studios in
London a course personally
really excited to see mark on my though
that ends up being true
question for wizard warlocks ask the
dark tonight looks like a female
I mean it's really been looking figure
it could be a couple characters though
we've already know that and drivers
going to be the villain in the movie but
he's not gonna be the only bad person
we do know there's not going to be a
giant group upset so this person is by
going to be the obvious build on that we
see like the Darth Vader take character
and Andy Serkis might be that big big
character in the shadows that won't
service to episode 89
he's the was over the trailer so I think
I've you know this character that we're
seeing with the lightsaber
existing in a relationship to in the
circus as Darth Vader in the Emperor did
in the original Trojan the prequels the
reason that everyone thinks that it
might be brie and
a tard will increase the edge the covers
brie and all the time is because the way
she's walking
packages very similar to this game is
thrown seen
dogs that you play this Jeff well I'm
talking about
this I mean it could be Adam driver
because he is one of the villains
it can also be done a Gleason he's
rumored to be one of the
antagonise to not the mean on but when
the antagonists
but I do think that is one of the new
cast members my at dhahran
will increase their Adam driver though
it is really love the idea
event evil Briana tart question 5 Jake
asked
would you consider doing a video on the
event to the Clone Wars cartoon
like a bonus video I'm totally open to
stuff like that
feel free if you have any requests about
old stuff please leave them in the
comments
the Clone Wars has a such as big history
and I kinda skipped over it like I
wasn't like a big Clone Wars fan while I
was on my towards the end
as did kinda jump on the bandwagon I
haven't watched The Lost missions yet
but I'm totally open to doing bonus
videos for it most the videos a new book
focus on the movies but I do count to
get and expanded Canon I really enjoy
doing rebels videos
it hasn't quite lived up to what I
wanted it to be but that's okay I mean I
have really high expectations for Star
Wars series
so next year are focusing on more movie
expanded can videos
remember that technically the only
things that are be considered as cannon
are like the new animated series the new
books the new comics
their few aspects from clone wars that
there including in the cannon
but you know technically it with all the
new stuff since Disney bought them
so I'll try to get into the new novels
but is always fun to look back at the
old stuff
question 6 energy player ass the force
move and/or of course
yes that means we gonna see he walks
again not necessarily
it is interesting to think that we go
back to end or I mean
we're gonna have to see like a couple
familiar places in addition to all the
new plants will visit
akin to see like disney's story team in
GG abrams getting really excited to show
these
familiar places that all the fans know
about in twist them in really unusual
ways
the idea that end or may be going
through some sort of like nuclear winter
is pretty crazy
I think in that situation all the walks
would be dead though as ingenious is
they are able to mount a complete
offensive
against the Empire now under an hour I
don't think that they would be able to
survive a nuclear winter
has in some rumors about why this
character in particular is on indoor
think about what happened in return to
the jet I and what might have been left
there
like really notorious items that might
have been left there
supposedly he is there to find them I
think there was also story in the
Expanded Universe
the doc
with that I think it's from Kevin G
anderson's jack and the trilogy
I think that's when that story took
place it's been a lot has never those
novels that was like
did next chilled you the came after the
Thrawn Trilogy I would actually say
applicable the novels the came out
like all the expanding universe novels
front row G still
in my mind the best then that committee
endorsed engine Academy Choji
that was when Luke Scott Walker started
as tablets the Academy on ya been
be I don't think that we're gonna see
iraq's again will prolly get some sorta
reference some sort of visual reference
the UART I cannot wait to start our
celebration I can only imagine
the amount of questions that are going
to be asked about the movie so
this detail like the e what detail will
definitely come out before the movie
are expected to be on the level %uh
easter egg like you know something
buried
in some the frame somewhere question for
seven christopher asked
what's up with the ass to make trades
head on a soccer ball why
I mean we don't know that international
a droid but it's rumored to be the Droid
built by DZ really that the character
with the aunt had to wean
no idea what its purposes other than
being a companion or scoping out salvage
sites
but this is supposed to belong to Daisy
really and it does look like it's on
tattoo wean
it does seem like they're trying to turn
it into a character on the level are too
although I don't think anything is ever
gonna be kept on the level or two
other than three PO that is or that
bounty hunter droid like I G 88
I'm it is a present we haven't seen any
of those I'm sure it some in the future
footage that they roll out we might see
some cybernetic life 78 forms a life
batino between Droid and cyborgs BBB
method right though it's been like its
control unit seems like its bag
medically
attached to the ball it's all like the
soccer ball whatever you wanna call it
it is an interesting idea I mean it
would give it you know much more
maneuverability
question 8 Keegan ass could you do a
video about lightsabers in the force in
general
and then how it's going to be related to
the movies in the characters
yeah I'm totally open to any ideas for
other bonus videos
I means for specific bones videos are
prolly but I'm most interested in
so yes totally I consider my breakdown
the force wanna be most interesting
beings and turned the lower
general or especially liked it. Old
Republic like all the comics and stuff
really got deep into that who knows how
much that they're gonna completely
rewrite
hopefully they don't complete rational
because I love it is really really
interesting
I totally open to that whenever you
bonus videos for stuff like that though
I
will specify like this is where this
information comes from
it might be thrown out it might be
completely different in the new trilogy
so even though Lucasfilm in Disney are
really thinking about it
specifically we can still talk about it
general or was like a really important
part
my enjoyment up the franchise during the
video games is all the comics in the
books
so America to you to talk about it
question for nine Louis
AZT do you know for sure is a dark to
die and not to sit
yes you talking about the curator no I
mean we don't know specifically but said
dark tonight or when the inquisitors I'm
actually more inclined to think that
it's one of the new questioners
I mean it either one or the new
inquisitors or it is
liked the new main character that's
going to take on that Darth Vader tape
brawl
which would make it either a fall in Gen
II or as said this but all this time
in storage rebels setting up the idea of
the inquisitors I believe the
inquisitors are gonna be very important
to the new trilogy
but that's where they're laying all its
groundwork in rebels now it's like a
backdoor
around the ruler to so like you can have
characters
the wheel light sabers but they don't
necessarily have the level training
or the indoctrination upstate characters
it's rumored that gwendolyn Chris the
is actually going to be one of those
type the characters that she's not going
to be said
should be part of the empire but she
will be when the inquisitors
and there the group that's kinda roaming
around the galaxy chasing people down
let me fill the vacuum left by beater in
the embers dat
just in general like in terms of rebels
think about
the big things that you see like the way
the Empire's organized its relationship
to the rest to the galaxy
but that's what things are going to look
like in the new trilogy
question for 10 workbook ask X means
flying over Lake reminds me up the
greatest hours video game
wrote squadron yes that was an awesome
video game rose water into place
after episode 4 this been up movie red 5
when is that going to take place episode
8 or nine
we don't really know when it's going to
take place it's rumored actually be when
the
earlier spin-off movies so presumably
you would take place sometime after
episode 7
you want two things I'm really looking
forward to an episode 7
is them setting the stage for what all
the spin-off movie is going to be
I think someone's been up movies won't
occurred concurrently with the new
trilogy
something might be prequels but I do
think this
X-wing movie will be set like during the
time up the new trilogy
that is a ports assuming that it will be
an x-wing movie
the ropes Potter novels were actually a
big part of the Expanded Universe
so if fans are that interested and
looking into the lives %uh
rebel pilots and I think they were
totally turn that into a movie at least
in the new Canon
was whether clinger read five instead it
broke five in your backyard
is Oscar Isaac but that doesn't
necessarily mean that he's going to show
up in that red 5 movie
question 11 chain as and you're always
talking about letting the Cora
I'm curious Charlie in what order jor
favorite if you had to pick between in
thrown Star Wars
or cora if you had a drop on what would
it be I me in terms the favorite I mean
Star Wars is my
original phantom but when I was growing
up I was like the first thing I was a
fan up
right now though I mean games roasters
dominate a lot of my
mind but core is ending so I would say
most my tensions encore right now
actually because ghettos hasn't gotten
started yet but isn't by than here
the nato his biggest on my mind is
rotates to whatever is actually
happening currently
I think the only way that I would drop
like one of those things is if I had
like so many things to do
did I wanted like blow my brains out
question 12 Daniel ass
will Bubba fed or some other men to
Lawrence be in the new movies
amino say definitely I mean it there in
the rebels cartoons are definitely going
to be in the movie in some way
think you should have been watching
rebels the character sabine rent is a
Mandalorian
in terms let's been up movies I mean if
we do get a boat that movie
he there still has to be alive or he has
to be like on his last legs
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions as is always at Hannaford do
Inc congratulations to the new giveaway
winner far as Bros
a toll it but that name just returned to
my channel for details unit when Lauren
as I give card
so here we get into some of the bigger
rumors about the film
sums got put this put a couple I talk
about it remembered these are all just
rumors
all unconfirmed a little bit has to do
with that dark tonight character
so if y'all know ryan Johnson was chosen
to write and direct
episode aid in he'll be working on apps
092 but I don't think that he's doing
both writing and directing on that film
supposedly Luke sky Walker is going to
be like
Joseph gordon-levitt and Bruce Willis is
character
from Lubar at least in relation to the
rainmaker
without spoiling that film complete
the just think about the remake a
character and how he appears in the film
like how we meet him
and what Bruce Willis and Joseph
gordon-levitt feel like they have to do
for certain part in the film that's
rumored to be what puts lube in
opposition to the other original cast
members
again just a rumor but if it's true it
be pretty amazing
that's why it's possible that that red
lightsaber building character could be
the rainmaker
take character up this neutral G but
part %uh the archive episode 7
will be the rise and that character and
I just realized that I forgot to mention
it during Mike
questions but that lightsaber is called
across card lightsaber
the reason it looks that way is because
is designed to be that way by this said
but the rainmaker type rumors are true
it's also possible but that character
could be just learning about the dark
side of the force
and so they could be inexperienced
invest building you know unless
Realty lightsaber in the reason for the
Cross card being paid it supposedly
supposed to keep you from having Empire
Strikes Back situation
or another jet I can slice your hand off
from an expense be I think because you
guys requested I'll do my favorite Jenae
stories from the Expanded Universe
so that's going the deep internet the
Old Republic all across
the previous Expanded Universe the
richest kinda been thrown out now a
pitcher's best buy that whenever I post
it but be sure to subscribe to get
everything
and again feel free to leave all your
quest for any bones but he is that you
wanna see
just a quick reminder new mobile Inc
sapir for your mobile phone or on your
tablet
you can now click on those is the same
as the link that I had over here but
right now
click here to watch the trailer again be
like 10 more times and click here for
the latest in front viral teaser
is like nine seconds of footage but it's
like the first team Thrones Season five
trailer we've gotten
the thank you so much for watching such
a high five Aussie guys tonight